hello i'm greg jarboe content marketing
faculty chair here at simply learned I'm
the president and co-founder of SEO PR
an award-winning content marketing
agency I'm also the author of YouTube
and video marketing an hour a day as
well as it contributed to four other
books I write for real SEO and a couple
of other blogs and I'm an instructor at
the Rutgers Business School as well as
being the video and content marketing
faculty chair here at simply learned I
[Music]
don't want to give you an introduction
to this new course on content marketing
what is this course are going to cover
what's in it for you why should you be
taking this
well for starters content marketing
isn't new back in 1895 John Deere
launched a magazine called the furrow
which provided information to farmers on
how to become more profitable that was
really the birth of content marketing so
it's been around for more than a hundred
years but frankly interest in this whole
area of content marketing took off
around 2011 right after Google's Panda
algorithm update improve the rankings of
so-called
high quality content and reduce the
rankings of so-called low-quality
content and all of a sudden the entire
industry was interested in how do I
create content that Google is going to
reward so this first module is going to
give you an overview of this training
course and it's designed to help content
marketing practitioners become more
effective and hopefully that coincides
with your goals so what is content
marketing and what do you have to do to
become a more effective content marketer
well for starters let's let's give you a
definition content marketing is defined
as quote a strategic marketing approach
which is focused on creating and
distributing valuable relevant and
consistent content in order to attract
and retain a clearly defined audience
and ultimately to drive profitable
customer action that's a quote that's
something you can use if somebody says
you know why are we doing this content
marketing program but one of the things
that I think all of us have been in this
field for a number of years realize is
that it isn't easy in fact there's an
annual serve
that the Content Marketing Institute
does and between 2015 and 2016 the
percentage of content marketers who said
their organizations were effective
actually went down so that got a lot of
us in the industry those of us who
practice content marketing those of us
who teach content marketing to reexamine
what it was that we were doing what our
assumptions were and how we might need
to clarify them going forward so that
you can be an effective content marketer
and one of the things that I came up
with you know a little bit earlier this
year is a series of questions or
concepts that we're going to explore in
this class and the goal here is not just
to get you started in content marketing
and I think that was the mistake that a
lot of people were doing it's like
here's a checklist go do this this and
this and suddenly you know you're a
Content marketer well this isn't a paint
by number kind of situation this is now
one where if you only read the
documentation you'd be able to assemble
your content marketing program
appropriately
content marketing is an art as well as a
science and if you want to be a
best-in-class content marketer and I
think that is what all of our goal is
not just to do it not just to be a
Content marketer but to be a really
effective one a good one a successful
one there are a number of things that
you need to do and they're listed here
I'm going to go through each one of them
over the next couple of slides so that
you get a sense of what each one entails
but as you sort of glance through this
list initially what you'll see is it's
not a short list
this is not a situation where can you
teach me all the tricks I need to learn
in about 15 minutes and then quote tada
I'm proficient at this now it is a
complex process but guess what if you
master each and every one of these steps
in this complicated process
it really sets you apart it's that you
apart from the average content marketer
and it actually makes you much more
valuable to your organization or clients
so let's go through each one of these
steps so that you have an idea of what
this course will cover